when asked if she thought she or someone  like her would become president one day  ocasio-cortez expressed doubt because of  her status as a woman of color in a  white male-dominated environment  while she believes  anything is possible she told GQ she is  aware of the reality of her potential  career trajectory so many people in this  country hate women she told GQ and they  hate women of color and it's not just  the right wing misogyny transcends  political ideology Left Right Center I  admit to sometimes believing that I live  in a country that would never let that  happen  so these people are insufferable these  are the same people by the way that  screamed and ranted and raved oh this is  a racist country this is racist racist  country is racist thrown through and  then that's the same country that  elected Obama twice  you just can't you know you can't speak  rational anything to these people